[Music]
welcome to fat man I'm Batman Kevin
Smith a muffin Arnie holy [ __ ] man we
are here again as always at the scum and
villainy Cantina right on Hollywood
Boulevard in Hollywood California put
your hands together so the folks at home
know you're real so much to talk about
so much to do I brought this box that
has Wakanda lettering all over it yeah
so we can open that up and see what's in
there but why I heard it this week
something happened to you something
familiar to me it feels like every
episode really like so what about your
heart yeah as an emergency room last
Wednesday because my chest will tell him
I said hi it's like hey Jeff Smith sent
me over hook me up guys they're like
that dude man he did not want to show
his dick so what'd they say they said
that I after like I had this comic book
signing last Wednesday and I was driving
home and didn't feel right and if
there's anything that I've learned from
from standing next to you for the last
four years its dick jokes are cool if
the other thing that I learned was
listen to your body yeah
and so I'm like this doesn't feel quite
right so I am going to veer away from
home and straight to the ER and to be
fair also your wife had gone through
something right my wife had I'd like an
angiogram because she was feeling some
chest [ __ ] and you would had something I
don't remember what that was a heart
attack
Yeah right and I also had angioplasty
but she had the angioplasty without a
heart attack
right she was like smart got in there
ahead of time it was like I'm gonna live
with that and the whole time that I'm
going to the ER I got like the cab Smith
checklist in my head like I am i
sweating profusely no am i nauseous no
thudding pain in my chest no all right
maybe this is something else but I still
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on
okay ultimately they said that uh that I
have hypertension it's yeah that's
just not a superhero which is actually
just a [ __ ] thing that happens to you
when you get old truly hypertension is
not the [ __ ] evil cousin of Optimus
Prime
this is a real killer
it usually precedes some heart stuff
that's when they usually tell you to
slow down throw you on some beta
blockers or something right so I'm on
three or four pills I'm not taking a day
because that's the life that you lead
when you're in your late 40s and that
[ __ ] up like to become a pill person
all of a sudden like I've never been a
pill person it's something I was kind of
like proud of and [ __ ] like I like my
mother is always taking a fistful of
meds to stay alive and like some of them
counteract the others side-effects of
the others and [ __ ] and I was like man
that ain't gonna be me
six months later I'm like I'll take my
seven pills a day please and it's like
it's the same thing I feel like underdog
the only way I could live and [ __ ] do
Adventures is a pop a pill for my ring
do you have like the day of the week
little thing that I do like an old like
a [ __ ] senior citizen from Florida I
have a Monday through [ __ ] Sunday set
of pill cases that like break up the day
in case I don't remember when to take
them and [ __ ] like hey my wife spent
playing like the pharmacist every
morning she wakes up she's like you take
your pills and I was like oh my god this
sounds like my childhood my mom was
always saying the same [ __ ] to my dad
you take your pills and [ __ ] so yeah I'm
a pill guy now and none of those get to
be like Flintstones chewables one is one
of them is a chewable aspirin that's
essentially like st. Joseph's aspirin
that's weird after the heart attack
though like you'll be on aspirin for the
rest of your life and I was like really
the like yeah it just [ __ ] helps and
stuff you should have been taking this
for years so I'm gonna start telling my
kid take aspirin to do it yeah like why
not it's cheap high yeah what so
ultimately alls ultimately all is fine
but you know blood pressure medication
because there had been some stress did
you have them look at any potential
blockage and stuff not yet I've got to
do a stress echocardiogram which again
this is like old people [ __ ] so if
you're like 20-something don't worry
it's coming for you yeah it's it's on
the way you just wait no I didn't think
it'd come for me you didn't think you'd
come for you [ __ ] comes and it comes
like a [ __ ] freight train and you're
really not expected for some reason I
was like
all right 60 I'm sure [ __ ] will start
falling apart new and the body's like
after the way you've treated us [ __ ] you
we quit and so trying to get the gang
back together man I know I think my body
was just jealous of all the attention
you were getting it's like [ __ ] you man
get some spotlight it's true man take it
some sweet attention [ __ ] oh so nice
talking to a friend of mine Vincent
prayer and he like [ __ ] scours the
Internet
he's like usually when celebrities get
sick or [ __ ] die like there's still a
contingency of people who are like [ __ ]
him to death but he was like I've been
reading the Internet and actually
looking for the negative [ __ ] and he's
like I don't see it man he's like people
people genuinely like you and I was like
that's a reason to [ __ ] stick around
and [ __ ]
if you horse then you [ __ ] blow it
what they say I'm [ __ ] Dark Knight
like you know you either become a hero
or live long enough to become the
villain and [ __ ]
should a [ __ ] stayed on the table and
sure that way everyone's like what a
good guy he was [ __ ] you know I make
Jay and Silent reboot and they're like
we wish he'd [ __ ] die I know it's
coming that's good for you good easy
criticism direct okay let's see what
else oh [ __ ] this is not here I don't
know if this is it's got to be we got at
the office an envelope inside the
envelope was wu-tang shirt but what
condo yeah so you're familiar with that
I have one of those absolutely
where'd you get it some nameless place
on the Internet right like a taxi or
something like that okay got one of
those shirts open up the card and it was
just like glad you're feeling better
blunt man we need you in the world love
your pal Method Man now Isis you know
part of me is just like well anybody
could [ __ ] send a note says Method
Man and stuff but he was on comic book
men mm-hm so and you know and somebody
told me like he loves the stuff he loves
with Jay and Silent Bob and so so maybe
it was but how if it is how [ __ ] cool
to get a wu-tang knockoff shirt
from Method Man that's kind of gene
unless he was like i'ma get some of his
money and I'm gonna make some yeah maybe
he's selling them on Etsy yeah okay
wu-tang clan Ian's not to [ __ ] with
goodness anyone you didn't well I don't
know I don't know how you put your heart
attack out there yeah here you don't
have our detector you had an incident I
know it wasn't even like a cardiac event
you know that night yeah some people
would just say you're jumpy that's it
you diagnose it bustling this Kittery
cat watch him okay let me see what let's
before we do anything else
oh [ __ ] we get to do 40 X tickets good
before we do anything else this box
arrived when when Black Panther opened
maybe the week black panther open doors
before it opened and it was buried under
a bunch of [ __ ] I've been cleaning out
my office all day finding amazing things
I found my coat from Dogma and I was
just like I was like don't put it on
don't put it on because there's no way
on earth that like it was gonna [ __ ]
fit cuz Dogma was 1998 and now I pretty
much way that and so I was like [ __ ] it
I'm gonna try to put on [ __ ] fit
clothes Sui and so I was like oh my god
I must be close to my Dogma weight and
I'm 5 pounds from my dog muy Thai lost
11 pounds since I started this diet and
[ __ ] so I'm gonna see how low I could go
but I'm at the dogma Kok level right now
how's that how's veganism treating you
[ __ ] blows like I can't get excited
about be honest but the program I'm on
right now though I'm not even in the
world of vegan choices I got one thing
that I'm meeting over and over and over
again instead for like two weeks and
then at it and when that ends then they
reintroduce food you know I eat like a
[ __ ] idiot so they're like we got to
retrain you how to even eat and [ __ ] so
that's what they've been doing on this
program because I was like I don't like
vegetables I'm great a guy that runs it
it's like he's going that's just some
[ __ ] story you tell yourself so you
don't have to eat vegetables grow up you
know
and so it's they're kind of harsh with
it and so thus so far though so good
I've been on it for like five this is
day 5 of all potatoes [ __ ] it's boring
it's not bad I remember when I first
heard it I was like potatoes
I [ __ ] love potatoes turns out I
really don't love potatoes I love the
[ __ ] you put on them till you know what
I love salt and a potato is just a
[ __ ] conductor system to get salt
into your mouth without just grabbing a
shaker and going like that and stuff
mixes it up dilutes it with the potato I
like the butter on top I loved Everett
the milk that goes into my chest I love
everything about mashed potatoes except
probably the root of it all man because
now you eat baked potatoes you can have
any potato you want [ __ ] sweet potato
Rus it's golden whatever [ __ ] I'm just a
russet guy so I've got two bags of
russet size like I could do this and I
know it could do it but oh my god it it
retrains you to see how you perceive
food and how the world throws food at
you and [ __ ] and now everywhere I go
it's like oh my god this whole you know
I get in [ __ ] they live where it's
like obey [ __ ] like that every song is
every sign every [ __ ] building every
billboard is just eat and then you
realize like yeah that's the easiest
[ __ ] thing to sell to anybody it's
the great uniter like none of us are
like [ __ ] eating you know like you could
be a Republican Democrat but come
together on like we got to eat so like
eating is really it's just [ __ ]
everywhere but I got to retrain my
eating habits because they're [ __ ]
bizarre and out of control so lately you
know it's been all potatoes nothing on
them just straight up playing potatoes
and stuff cassettes no I know like the
Martian he got there sweetness [ __ ] up
of drugs but it trains you to to be like
and the diet's like you use many
potatoes you want go [ __ ] nuts you
could literally ten pounds of potatoes
but you won't
and they said that to me and I was like
I might and now day five I really will
not like you know you're like in the
morning it's like it's not like I'm
choking it down but I'm like oh man I
only want to eat this like you lose your
appetite so it breaks you and retrained
you to accept other things later on also
shows me how deep I could go into the
day without eating because that whole
like breakfast is the most important
meal as is [ __ ] propaganda so we
weren't made that way like when we were
[ __ ] rooting around for [ __ ] and then
hunting for game and [ __ ] still not
have language skills and [ __ ] nobody was
like when's breakfast you know some [ __ ]
that came in the new world when once we
had like in the diet they talked about
there's three things that you know was
the biggest threats to humanity cold
darkness and starvation and though I
guess a species we've literally
conquered all three like you could if
you want [ __ ] light you could turn on
a light in the middle of the darkness if
you want heat that's easy to [ __ ] put
together now as well and food is
everywhere so much so that like even
poor folks in this country are heavy I
was [ __ ] lower I always say lower
lower lower middle class I was [ __ ]
government cheese eating poor when I was
a kid but I was fact as I was a
government cheese you know so so it's
there is--there Irae who come up with a
diet is like when you the human body is
is built to like put [ __ ] aside the fat
is meant to be stored you know for
winter we used to go through climates
and [ __ ] like that but now we just store
up for a winter that's never coming
winters not coming you know so and it
just lives on our body so in the five
days I've been eating [ __ ] potatoes
which is [ __ ] so boring well again it
takes although I realized like I ate for
more entertaiment like now that like
eating is boiled down to a baked potato
and [ __ ] suddenly like the there's no
like oh I know what I'm gonna do today
cuz everything used to center around
first I'll go out and get some food then
I'll do two things then get some more
[ __ ] food then come home watch a
movie while I eat [ __ ] food and then
dessert you know so now it's all about
like oh I don't really want that like
you know like you start to figure [ __ ]
out
I don't like potatoes it just like
[ __ ] salt and you
now you could cheat but I don't cheat
like if you cheat what's the [ __ ]
point and honestly in [ __ ] five days
I've lost 12 pounds so it's like I
shouldn't really cheat so far it's
[ __ ] working
couldn't you tell that same story with
pizza no because the sugar and salt
content basically human beings crave
three things that are bad for us
salt sugar and fats and pizza contains
all that [ __ ]
Chinese blood sugar in the sauce and
salt so it wouldn't like the reason I'm
dropping weight is because if you eat
plant potatoes with nothing on them my
sodium content has dropped to like
nothing
I'm not putting salt in my body so I'm
pissing like a racehorse and that's
where most of the weight comes from so
if it was pizza I just be storing it
like I'd go back to storing it where
I've stored [ __ ] but the psychological
story would still be the same in that if
you ate nothing but pizza every day all
day for like three weeks
wouldn't you at some point get tired of
pizza that's like saying if you ate
[ __ ] every day for the rest of your
life wouldn't you get tired of [ __ ]
some [ __ ] you never get tired of man
pizza pizza is just the it's an insane
savory combination of like of the three
things that human beings great that's
why it's so comforting it's comfort food
and stuff just dangle [ __ ] peach in
front yeah I'm just no you can I'm fine
like believe me you couldn't like
suddenly like I couldn't be triggered if
you were like Lucky Charms I'm like you
know I'm kind of dialed in I read Penn
Jillette's book this is where I got all
this from presto it's called he lost
like a hundred [ __ ] pounds he looked
great and I always thought he had had
like a gastric bypass but no he just ate
the way this guy told him to eat and so
you know Adam Rifkin the director hooked
me and Penn up I interviewed him at the
house before but and I've seen him a
zillion times but I you know we weren't
like close enough for me to be like hey
man how'd you do that so when I hit him
up he was like hey I'll read my book and
if you like it I'll hook you up with a
guy so I liked the way he handled the
program my personnel and his personality
kind of similar and Submission the idea
of like somebody's like you got one
thing you're only doing that for people
that generally their whole lives do
whatever they want is appealing it's why
I got married to have somebody to be
like
No you know so it's nice to have this
guy running the diet be the same thing
he's just like no and you're like
alright well for how long he's like two
weeks of no and you're like alright well
I could get my head around two weeks it
was 47 years of yes so two weeks of no
should be a fun thing to do
so it reworked your psychology as well I
hope and honestly like now I literally
start thinking about like I'm on a
desert island where I'm just like what
would I have when I got back to
civilization and I've boiled it down to
the ultimate superfood for me peanut
butter and jelly sandwich that's it if I
if I wish this diet was like just peanut
butter jelly I was like I got this [ __ ]
psyched [ __ ] down man but
unfortunately it's not but good news is
peanut butter and jelly is vegan so to
go back to your question the vegan sucks
but there's peanut butter and jelly so I
can't [ __ ] complain no more animal
products though which is fine I'm still
not sitting there going I want to eat a
[ __ ] cows nuts like it's I feel like
I've had my full of that and stuff and
in fact I was feeding the dogs chicken
today and I wasn't like oh god my
[ __ ] ex loved I realized I don't
really like chicken as much as I like
barbecue sauce if you took that away
like if the chicken away and still gave
me barbecue sauce which literally you
can eat as a vegetarian that's what I
was looking for the most but that's me
looking for sugar you know suddenly you
start breaking all this [ __ ] down my
wife or my whole life yeah most of my
whole life but definitely from like
clerks on once it was my own boss and
[ __ ] moved out of my parents house I was
like I'm gonna [ __ ] eat whatever I
want man and I never really bothered to
stop to think well what does your body
need it's always like what do you want
am I gonna want [ __ ] Lucky Charms and
pizza and then [ __ ] a sub and [ __ ]
like that and then we'll move on to the
main course basically it's it's now a
matter of before you go for that thing
like do you want do you need it or do
you just want it and if you just want it
why do you want it do you want it
because you have [ __ ] excellent
memories of it like Penn and his book
gives great examples where he's like my
mom used to make this blueberry pie with
hand-picked [ __ ] blueberries and he
tell from his writing
dougies mom and he dug his mom's [ __ ]
cooking so he's like but every time I
eat a blueberry pie I didn't not have
that same experience that I had to eat
my mom's blueberry pie so many factors
are [ __ ] missing but I still chase the
dragon he said I have pizza with Lou
Reed once well in the greatest moments
of my life and every time I pizza after
that I compare it to that moment but
it'll never be that [ __ ] great
because it wasn't the pizza I was
sitting there with [ __ ] Lou Reed and
stuff so every piece of pizza I try to
eat man's not gonna bring me back to
that [ __ ] moment so you know it
starts breaking the way you think about
food it's kind of interesting but it
doesn't make me one of those cats it's
like now you got to do it too now I just
talked to all my friends going like tell
me about food my friend Malcolm was here
for with us this whole week and at first
I almost had him going on the diet with
me but he was going through some [ __ ]
with his movie so it's like I need to be
crisp I need to be able to eat whatever
I want or I'll turn into a [ __ ] which
was a commentary on what I had become
like by day four the potatoes I was like
everything sucks so so Malcolm you know
was like we went to see Black Panther
again he hadn't seen it yet I was like
oh it was perfect opportunity to go see
Black Panther again so you know he was
like we got to the concession stand I
was like big bottle of water and he's
like well I can't get anything while
heart attack guy is here and I was like
who's heart attack me [ __ ] you you're
like yeah I said get whatever you want
honestly like I'm dialed in on a program
go ahead and he got a big bucket of
popcorn and it Y bi the being on this
potato famine if you will like since
there's no your taste buds aren't being
[ __ ] really fired up and your palates
being cleansed everything smells
intensely more intensely like suddenly
aromas go [ __ ] way deeper suddenly
I'm smelling things I never smelled
before because they didn't spell them
because my palate was clogged just
assured her so fast so Malcolm's popcorn
man was like like I could have come din
my pants inhaling it it smelled so good
I was like let me just sniff it and I
was in hell I probably got popcorn lung
handling it's so [ __ ] odd but you
start appreciating [ __ ] like that but
I'm not really a big popcorn guy like
I'm okay with it but it's not my go-to
so I wasn't really tempted but the
[ __ ] smell of it was fantastic so I
like being around my wife - she was just
like I can't eat in front of it I was
like oh my god like eating in front of
me is like porn right now
I like show me what I can't have it's so
wrong you naughty boy you know so anyway
back to the boxes so I got this box and
it has what Conda writing on it
we'll put it down here so it doesn't
block the view and stuff so it's a
promotion for let's see can you read
that upset in it won't unleash your
flavor that's brisk you want me to read
the whole [ __ ] thing I came over
fifty years ago the world was introduced
to the hero the legend the king of
Wakanda the Black Panther since then
we've seen Gods fly men build suits of
armor and aliens travel across the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but have we
never ever seen but we have never seen
anything like this a royal African
nation technologically superior and
hidden for centuries Marvel Studios
Black Panther is a piece of art that
will echo for centuries Marvel's for
throughout culture and the history of
filmmaking we are proud to celebrate the
creators both past and present who have
brought this character to life we salute
these creators who through inked film
and performance will inspire the next
generation to bring their own creativity
to the world
now that's brisk isn't that nestea or
something like that's a lot of fancy
language for a nicety right there
okay top layer well here let's do bottom
layer first okay bottom layer you like
you guys can't see what's in there yeah
your yeah your I'm giving you everything
in this box because you're the huge
[ __ ] Panther fan but here is what
looks like a box does it open I know
your beads are they let me see well do
not kill anybody
you did the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] they are the
leads that's badass man so what are they
are they replicas or this [ __ ] work hold
on oh god I hope they [ __ ] work I'm
sure I'll get it works certificate of
authenticity usually means that [ __ ]
don't work
is it cuz go around your hand oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
alright I need two hands you talk while
I put this down okay I wow I feel like
I'm [ __ ] done here we go good job
this is black panther only in theaters
press to activate by brisk what does it
do
are those other sharees bracelets does
that do something awesome
[ __ ] that a black panther head it's
a black it's a it's a can of ice too
that was almost so cool it's a good I
guess you could can you remove it or not
yeah you can it's like a beer cozy or
something like that but it's over a can
of Diet brisk that has the Black Panther
name but what is this says press to
notice what Condon technology at its
finest press to activate well that makes
it cold maybe just Oh could you imagine
that you like cold up your [ __ ] drink
oh there's a little speaker on the bill
now is that a speaker no it's just a
base wait oh that was the top I'm really
I really [ __ ] assigned more reality to
it than it needed there's an Eric kill
monger diet brisk because honestly if
there's anything that I think about when
I think of like Jenna Seidel maniacs I
think of iced tea I mean he wasn't shape
so he did it without the extra calories
and he's like see all these marks on my
body there's all the iced tea I drank to
get here diet brisk can't kill monger
let's see we got a can of Shirdi as well
surely and is that also diet oh they're
all diet you sure yeah I guess everyone
was thin in that movie yeah a Nakia iced
tea they all got pictures of all the
characters from the flick and of course
the koi egg
wow that looks cool I wonder if they're
selling him in stores has anybody seen
these in stores they're beautiful I
would totally like that wouldn't make me
want to buy ice tea and then I'd be like
I don't like diet iced tea you know it's
[ __ ] but it's a good-looking [ __ ]
can alright what is this we hope you
enjoy this limited edition collaboration
between brisk and Marvel Studios Black
Panther the first of their kind
materials included would not be
responsible without tremendous
contribution of our partners PepsiCo I
guess they make the iced tea Marvel
complex Olsen United Entertainment Group
Inc work crawl now RCC L bless you proto
labs
Arta Group ball rock love and LA rocks
alright so they gave us ice-t ball is my
favorite but look at this
well Conda forever the creators of
Marvel Studios Black Panther from the
pages of Marvel Comics to the silver
screen the Black Panthers will kondal
lives on forever through the lenses of
dynamic creators we invite you to
explore this limited edition pack
celebrating the artistry and imagination
beyond the film every item captures a
special piece of inspiration from the
works of writers production designers
costume stylists and graphic novel
artists in partnership with film
creators we aim to support the next
generation of creatives through our
mentoring
initiative the brisk creators class
there you go folks there's your some
free [ __ ] information this is you get
some money out of these iced tea people
we hope you enjoy this collection and
it's hidden features be sure to see
marvel studios black panther in theaters
February 16th as if they needed help the
brisk creators and creators class look
it up online see if that's useful to
anybody okay but what they included here
was a little black panther prelude so it
tells the story right before the movie
begins looks like a limited edition in
this package only comic and what's that
this is like a photo still press kit
thing oh so it's just a beautiful book
on it but this is the jewel in the
[ __ ] crown man take that out and tell
us what that is
Kiska sea mm it's a Samsung shiny thing
and it's got writing on them you know
what happens now what happens now
determines what happens to the rest of
the world
T'Challa that's a pretty self-important
iPad right then what do they call it
when it's not an iPad tablet yeah whose
is a samsung it's a Sam said it might
blow up it's a Samsung JC open the doors
it's a Samsung how nice man so honestly
we're like I guess this promotes the
movie hopefully it promoted a movie that
needed no [ __ ] help yeah but could
you imagine they sent this to like
[ __ ] the likes of me like we should
send this to the cast this should be a
wrap gift this just goes to show you get
way better mail than anybody else like
Method Man is sending you t-shirts and
Samsung is sending you iced tea it's
true it was kind of a brag email session
unbidden to my house I'm gonna give this
to you you want this I figured like you
would probably if you didn't use the
iPad you and your kid loved the moment
yeah I have children yeah no they would
they would dig the [ __ ] out of it better
than
in the hands of one of the fat men on
Batman than none at all so Wow heads is
a good life good job brisk
I'm selling us a movie that need any no
selling good suet 1.1 billion dollars
that where we are with it right now
welcome Reverend the other now one point
1 billion dollars puts it ahead of [ __ ]
these I mean not for nothing I'm not
like sucking their dick but these cans
look amazing it's crazy man that's
really nice
all right back to you I think I think
when they open them when you open the
cans did you see don't drink me
colonizer 1.1 billion puts it where in
terms of the marvel hit list obviously
Avengers still remain strong at number 1
Jersey and Ultron are still above it so
this has a chance of catching Ultron yes
there there's I mean it's a long shot
because Ultron I think it was like 2.2
wasn't did that am i right
anybody want to double check me on
nobody's got the Internet look it up
real quick and see because the Samsung
magic box is not plugged in so we can't
check but yeah it is it is poised to be
the number 3 I think behind no I think
it's actually about to surpass Dark
Knight so it'll be the number 2
superhero it has surpassed Dark Knight
so it's the number 2 superhero movie of
all time and I think the number 2 Marvel
release of all time we're all said and
done it might crawl past Ultron and you
know just stand within well who knows I
mean it's only been what how many weeks
it's been three weeks I mean it only
just opened in China and the fact that
it was one character if you look at all
the single character Marvel flicks only
Iron Man 3 which was coming off the heat
of the Avengers right and it is fine
movie in and of itself I love that movie
so I'm not taking anything away from it
but that is the only standalone Marvel
character and he had two movies to fuel
them and the Avengers to take off to go
past a billion dollar
so doing it one character only who had
no warmup other than you know Fox in
America's Civil War and stuff which I
guess is kind of a prelude but to do
that single-handedly without a [ __ ]
team of superheroes behind you yeah now
the question is if that movie is is that
1.1 billion now easily gets to let's say
one seven one eight if not [ __ ] two
what is [ __ ] infinity war is gonna
make it's gonna take all the money from
the world we'll have to sell them
countries in order to make holes really
man would you like Lichtenstein sure
[ __ ] it we'll take it winter will be
coming at that point because none of us
will have [ __ ] funds they're just
marvel at this point is like a really
good hearted and and legal Enron they
just have all the money they control our
lives and [ __ ] that like we're shutting
down the grid and you're like [ __ ] for
them to do is start their own currency
like bit like a Bitcoin but for Marvel
oh [ __ ] Marvel medallions yeah or what
Infinity stones infinite Cohen infinite
cool that's right there's a whole brand
sitting right there see
you're welcome Marvel like they need my
help I was trying to think what is the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I was tryna what the eye of
agamotto mmm the coins could be all I of
agamotto skål Maggie's got [ __ ] 20
Aggies on the race and she okay
so one point 1 billion [ __ ] that's a lot
that's impressive the [ __ ] I saw it like
I said a second time this week and
absolutely still loved it it held up
like crazy and it's so well [ __ ] made
and stuff when we left there my friend
Malcolm was like oh my god because he
liked Fruitvale station and he's not a
real big superhero movie guy but he's
like [ __ ] that was good you said he made
Creed I gotta see that and I was like
you didn't [ __ ] see Creed as a Creed
is it like Black Panther is wonderful
and and a magic act in and of itself but
what he did with Creed is nothing short
of [ __ ] Jesus raising Lazarus from
the dead
that [ __ ] was biblical he made me care
about [ __ ] Rocky Balboa again well I
was like I'm [ __ ] back and then to
like the next one creed to is by still
Honam I got [ __ ] I'm out again but that
Creed you could feel it was made with
passion it was like him and his like
high school buddy
had always wanted to make a movie about
you know the other guy in Rocky not
[ __ ] Rocky and [ __ ] they did a great
job so I was plugging Malcolm all week
on I can't believe you haven't seen
[ __ ] Creed man went after him as well
too about because I saw call me by your
name and Malcolm hasn't and Malcolm's
very proud out gay man and I was like I
think that makes me a better gay person
than you and he got seriously testy
ruzek no doesn't you're profiling me a
gay man has don't like a gay movie I was
like yes like yeah you at least have to
be interested it was kind of funny
argument he was like nah I don't I don't
have to like gay move at all I don't he
goes I don't really like gay movies I
was like you make them like you make all
your movies are gay themed documentaries
he was trying to win the argument I just
couldn't do it this fun anyway back to
the [ __ ] show yeah
next piece I guess we're into the news
went to the news I saw some movies the
last couple of days oh I saw a wrinkle
in time oh that wasn't um fine
well I mean okay here's the thing
okay I I remember reading the books in
elementary school I don't remember much
about the books beyond the fact that
they were like kind of weirdly churchy
in ways that I didn't quite like it's
there are lots of like Christian
underpinnings and so does the line the
whishing the Wardrobe like a CS Lewis
yeah sneak attack of part of what
Madeleine L'Engle was all about but I
have since forgotten all of that [ __ ]
and there was there's an introduction at
the beginning from Ava Duvernay who said
who's telling viewers to keep in mind
that this is in the beginning of the
movie yeah literally it's like her on
screen a disclaimer introducing you to
the movie in which she says oh [ __ ] I
never thought of that [ __ ]
I'm gonna do that for the rest of the
[ __ ] movie because you can open with
a joke and [ __ ] do like 5 minutes of
material then be like now yoga hosers
yeah it's there for you if you want it
man and then you know you'd be setting
it up man like even if they hate the
movie like he was funny at the beginning
of the movie it should especially if
I've went out there and recorded an
intro where I'm like look a lot of
people don't like this I love this movie
but a lot of people don't like this
movie so if you don't like the movie
it's cool but let me tell you a story
about jerking off and then like go on to
just gild the lily a little bit so what
did she say did she kill the lily she
basically said this is a children's
movie made for children this is you know
it's from my heart from growing up as a
black girl in Compton and not feeling
the fantasy was for me like finding a
way to tell story about sort of heart
and heroism and what it means to see a
different kind of hero okay and it is
it's a weird sort of I guess deflating
of what the movie is because I've seen
children's movies that do not require me
to be in the mindset of a children's
movie you're not I mean like you don't
have to tell me all right by the way
Incredibles he's kind of a kids movie
but I don't know maybe you'll like it
which feels a little bit like what she
did with wrinkle on time right and the
first half an hour is a little bit
clunky as they introduce your heroine
MacMurray and sort of her world and how
her father disappeared like eight years
ago and she's always been at odds and
this sounds like the Chris Nolan movie
it's a you know it's a little and it's
Disney ish with a little bit of contact
to like the idea of my dad is lost in
space so it's got that two totally
little [ __ ] oh dear but once once you
get to their adventure proper once
you've met your three weird-ass missus
is Oprah Winfrey Reese Witherspoon and
Mindy Kaling how are they
Oprah is God which we all kind of knew
and and she also appears for the first
time in the movie like 8,000 feet tall
so she's just stared she's like dr.
Manhattan but like a nice one who likes
like tells you [ __ ] you need to know
about your son Sherwin Oprah Winfrey
watch the movie for the first time she
was like this is the right relationship
like everybody gets a car so like so
when why is it just alright because the
this sort of narrative rigor is not what
this movies about it's not about making
sense sort of dramatically and
structurally it is about making like
emotional sense and there's moments in
this movie that absolutely soared
there's there's a couple of sequences
that feel like they're out of a Miyazaki
movie there's a couple of sequences that
are absolutely about the relationship
between a father and a daughter who's
been missing each other and they once
the you reconnect with them and Chris
Pine is the [ __ ] rock star of this
movie because who knew Chris Pine was is
good we all did from Wonder Woman yeah
but he like he was the second most
[ __ ] a [ __ ] person in that movie
like he fell in love with her of course
but like he was equally as [ __ ]
charming and like he's always been even
it's cooked like he did a minor miracle
years ago nobody talks about any more
[ __ ] made you forget William
Shatner was Captain Kirk is Kirk was so
[ __ ] strong and he didn't do an
impression no he did Kirk which I'm sure
William Shatner Billy no he did a
[ __ ] impression pay me my [ __ ]
money but he doesn't seem to ever be
doing an impression Shatner but [ __ ]
nailed Kirk man I think that kids are
good actor you know his dad is yeah
[ __ ] was on ships once he was he
wasn't not even like you know was
watching John he was the captain guy
that's crazy man like I know man I'm
Chris Pine sitting at home like my dad's
on chips one day I'm gonna have sex with
wonderful
on a motorcycle that belonged to my dad
from chips I've always thought he was
good but it wasn't until hell or high
water that I was blown away by him as an
actor really yeah like I liked him in
the first thing was I saw was yes the
joe carnahan movie was it called smokin
aces i confuse it with stroker ace the
old [ __ ] just the best movie you like
strawberries yeah I had this I mean his
way off topic my mom he would go back
but me and Malcolm we're talking this
week and he was talking about he's
leaving tomorrow but on Saturday there's
a Burt Reynolds event at the Egyptian
theater where Burt Reynolds gonna watch
like Smokey and the Bandit and and all
right no that's what I asked right away
best little whorehouse in Texas and
Sharky's machine I don't know if he's
watching all three but he's doing
commentary after one of them and
Malcolm's like oh man that's my [ __ ]
dream to see [ __ ] Burt Reynolds and I
said you never saw him like he loved him
as a kid he idolized Burt Reynolds and
he goes no I never saw him in my [ __ ]
life and then it started a whole day of
Burt discussions and Malcolm's this kind
of guy where he's like where do you
believe it all went to hell for Burt
Reynolds you know and I'm like I thought
you were a fan [ __ ] I said I
don't think it ever went to hell because
he had like the Boogie Nights resurgence
which had striptease at that point stuff
but there was a point I said where you
know I don't know I guess by the time he
gets a Cannonball Run 2 and he goes
[ __ ] [ __ ] stroker race is the
beginning of the end
anyone on a 20 minute dissertation about
Loni Anderson that it was like [ __ ] you
saw a lot more in that movie than I ever
did I mean that's why I showed up was
for Loni Anderson but did you like them
do you remember what it's about
um barely I remember Loni Anderson was
in it
opposite WKRP fan and oh yeah so you
didn't go for Burt you went for Lonnie
yeah I was a simple boy stroker ace
stroke smokin aces so you guys we thank
you for being my pensive my Harry Potter
it was
first time I saw him was in smokin aces
and I remember Affleck had said because
Affleck was in the movie briefly right
he's in the first few minutes he said I
worked on this movie with joe carnahan
and this [ __ ] kid who's in the scene
with me is amazing and it when I saw the
movie it was in Chris Pine but like he's
really good in this movie he's really
good in every movie like you said but
like where this is good on SNL as an SNL
host it was good that's a tough gig and
he was pretty funny in it yeah but like
where this movie soars is when it leans
into this sort of hard on its sleeve
straight up like sort of heroic
narrative even like heroic emotional
narrative in a way that it doesn't
include sort of rigorous storytelling
right and so I mean it's super short
it's an hour and 45 minutes long some of
the visuals are lovely again some of the
emotions are great but like it's not an
amazing movie it's like a pretty good
shot and ambitious because this book you
know it has long been rendered esteemed
as unfilmable right and the fact that
there was some version of it that feels
like it works in any way is a minor
miracle but the disclaimer leave a bad
taste to your mouth and then nothing so
okay yeah because it's very much about
like I've wanted to make this movie
since I was a kid and I finally got to
do it so enjoy the I'll tell a quick
Dogma story but unfortunately it's gonna
warm the heart but for a minute it's
gonna make everybody go because there's
a name nobody wants to hear
I'm just do Sarah Lewis yes excellent
we're putting Dogma out there and
there's a lot of religious protests
against the movie and death threats and
[ __ ] 300 thousand pieces a hate mail two
of them were [ __ ] flat-out death
threats we stopped opening our mail for
a while when we showed the movie it can
they installed metal detectors and in
the palais because people were worried
about people bringing in guns and [ __ ]
like that
so the chairman of Miramax maybe I could
do it without saying his name there you
go the chairman of Miramax was like you
have to put a disclaimer at the head of
this movie because I had a card at the
beginning of the movie before it began
that said first is line by line came up
and it said men go crazy and
congregations they only get better
one by one and it seemed like a very
serious quote and then it's gave the
author of the quote Gordon Sumner and
then it puts sting because it's a
[ __ ] staying lyric and [ __ ] and so
the chairman of Miramax is like [ __ ] the
sting lyrics he's going you got to put
something at the head of this that says
that you were only joking that this is a
comedy and I was like are you kidding me
why is that necessary like doesn't the
rubber poop monster tip everybody off to
the hat and everyone was so worried
about [ __ ] people getting hurt and
[ __ ] that I broke down I was like okay I
will put a disclaimer up but can it be
funny and so they said yes and that's
why there's that at the beginning of
dogma the disclaimer begins like it said
something about the platypus it's like
this movie isn't meant to blah blah blah
and then it's God has a sense of humor
look at the platypus and then when the
movie came out it was the early days of
the Internet the early heyday is the
internet and there were three platypus
enthusiasts who were like go [ __ ]
yourself they can't [ __ ] win is my
point okay so I saw that I saw you
recommend it though I do recommend you I
do I do I want to see it it looks like I
loved a movie that Disney did
live-action I still support didn't
Disney live-action because I grew up on
it like [ __ ] Bedknobs and Broomsticks
is Disney live-action so I they did a
movie a couple years ago that nobody
seemed to go for but I [ __ ] loved
which was tomorrow land and the haul the
trailers reminded me of tomorrow night
Tomorrowland got such a bad rap I saw
that movie on a [ __ ] plane and I was
just I was transported like by the plane
yes but the movie also took but he's
such a [ __ ] crazy wonderful emotional
place such a good flick so I'm gonna go
see ya it's really for sure last night I
saw a Tomb Raider oh [ __ ] yeah is that
like bless you did you did you ever play
the Tomb Raider games like once and it
was really frustrating for me lots of
puzzle solving and well I never played
it on like a computer I played it on
like Sega Saturn there
version of it and I was just like yeah I
like the Bullwinkle game lots more
seemed more my speed yeah I mean I've
been playing Tomb Raider games since
1996 or whatever the [ __ ] whenever the
first one came out uh somebody will
check me on that and yell at me on the
internet but I've been playing ever
since I saw the Angelina Jolie movie
which you know how was it man it was
fine for the time you know like I
remember when that movie came out and it
was alright female action hero and she's
absolutely Center this thing and she's
there's no romance story really it's
just [ __ ] female Indiana Jones just
with giant guns and other things but
it's super [ __ ] hokey like I watched
it again over the weekend and it just
doesn't really hold up but in any real
way but they released a couple of video
games in the last like two or three
years like the new Lara Croft games they
sort of reposition the character and
make her story way more about survival
way more about you know what was the old
story the old story was just like she
loves to party yeah yeah lots of that
but it was very much like I am you know
a rich heiress and I'm all about the
Croft mansion and I'm a fortune on her
and oh that's why they keep putting her
dad in these movies yeah he seems to be
a big character right like the dad dies
and leaves with all this money and some
question fulfill and find the temple of
Cyrus or whatever the [ __ ] this one is
is way more about like it still has the
father-daughter story still has the on a
quest for [ __ ] but it's more about her
overcoming sort of her own internal
blocks against her being awesome and
like embracing who she is and where she
comes from and there are a couple of
sequences in this movie that feel like
pulled right out of Uncharted she'll
pull right out of Indiana Jones there's
there's this ball than a good way or bad
way just like you know inspired homage
more authoritative but there's the scene
you see a little bit over the trailer
where she's going over a waterfall and
she holds onto this like rusted-out
because that's a rope clip where she's
about to go over and yeah just a
whelming is there a lot of jump there's
a lot of [ __ ] jumping in his movie
they're like look what a Lara Lara Croft
fans want [ __ ] jumping man
so make sure there's a lot of jump do
whatever you want put her dad in it but
MAPE a lot of [ __ ] jump it but it
feels like the sequence from the second
Jurassic Park movie went on the glass
yeah in the in the [ __ ] like RV
that's going over a cliff
like that that sequence still works a
lot of Jurassic Park 2 is problematic
not another [ __ ] like me 2 waves it's
just kind of problematic like especially
following the great Jurassic Park but
that sequence is like cinema classic
yeah it's still real hose up and so that
sequence sort of spills and it evolves
and pays lots of homage to that it's a
totally fun kind of popcorn movie like
it's Raiders light and I'm here for
Raiders like how long is it to 15 a
mouthing Alyssa I got potatoes I got to
eat I can't be here okay
I took a [ __ ] baked potato with me to
the Black Panther yeah right before I
left I was putting on my clothes I said
Jen can you heat a potato for me cuz
they're all pre-baked and stuff so she
heated in the microwave and she's like
he anything now I said no I'm gonna put
it in tin foil and bring it to the movie
theater and she goes you're so [ __ ]
eccentric and I was like oh I've snuck
food in before she's like yeah but not
produce like but it worked out man again
I got to enjoy the [ __ ] out of you know
what else I saw good [ __ ] movie you
saw a movie said too right I did you got
a third one I got a third thing I saw
okay let me do my movie and then you do
your third okay do you see this [ __ ]
trailer for this movie thoroughbreds no
[ __ ] dude it's it's good I don't know
who did it I didn't memorize the
directors name these two actresses in it
are [ __ ] astounding the movie is that
feels like like heavenly creatures
crossed with whit Stillman's
metropolitan it's it's a it's a weird
yeah it's a weird hybrid it's set in a
world of privilege but it's about like
the
a sociopath and a psychopath who are
both like teenage girls really well
acted insanely well written and
performed it's almost plays like a play
very stylized delivery of dialogue
definitely worth checking out the
theater I saw it in was look like a
little crowded so I think it's doing
some business I think focus put it out
but I [ __ ] absolutely loved it it
reminded me of the movies I used to
watch before I became a filmmaker like
it feels like a throwback to an era that
excited me about indie film in the first
place so I dug it like crazy man yeah
it's definitely worth seeing what is the
third thing that you saw I saw the first
three episodes of Jessica Jones season 2
oh [ __ ] you started how goes the trip so
far so far to slow burn which might be a
generous way to say a little cloudy I
mean I like it because I like that world
I like those characters I by the end of
season by season but the end of episode
3 a big thing finally [ __ ] happens
which is kind of great
ok but it's it's it's a bit of a sit to
get to the big thing that actually
happens what is it but I don't spoil it
but is it big does it involve other
characters it involves who is going to
at least from what we can tell will be
the big bad if not the entire season at
least the first arc of the season yeah
the way Marvel seems to be breaking
these into chunks of 6 yeah and so by
the sixth episode something big that
spins the the season the next way this
is the big thing for at least the first
the first act of the show is it an old
returning villain no not that I can tell
brand-new brand-new but yeah I mean all
the performances are really strong the
writing is really good it's just taking
is the season of all female directors
right yeah that makes sense the absolute
sense yeah for the first time ever
they're like it's a show about a woman
all the directors should be women you
know seems like a no-brainer but it took
a while you can keep going
[Applause]
but more for sense of like being a
completionist then you're like I [ __ ]
dig it there is so much to [ __ ] watch
there honestly is like it's kind of
becoming the problem isn't it like makes
you not want to go pitch anything cuz
you're like what are the chances like it
used to used to I I think the chances of
getting like there's a lot more places
so everyone's got the content hunger
hungry but you know everyone wants like
game thrones where I'm like I don't
[ __ ] have Game of Thrones in me i
watch the show do you need a show about
a guy who talks about the show because
i'd be ok for that but yeah man it's
crazy there's so much to keep up with
there's a ton so I will totally watch
the rest of it because I like the first
season so much at the very least I can I
did I love that first season as well it
feels like it's been a minute since that
show happened it has been Marvel takes
their time both in the episodes and in
releasing the episodes so that's what
you've watched yeah [ __ ] a alright
we're moving on to something else we can
do some news let's dive into the goddamn
news that's what we're here to do ladies
and gentlemen fat man on Batman digs
into the utility belt remember that and
brings you the news give it up for mark
barnard and he looked up the news the
fruits of my google searching are here
do you know who's finally gonna be
[ __ ] Superman Nicolas Nicolas [ __ ]
cage yes that proves if you wait long
enough and you're patient everything you
want in life will eventually happen good
for Nicolas Cage man he's doing this in
a Teen Titans go cartoons movie yeah
like he's finally got a voice the Man of
Steel well I mean come on he's he's a
little Haggard at this point I'm not
sure that's the way I interviewed him at
Sundance he's [ __ ] he looks like the
same Nic Cage that I fell in love with
in valley girl he's he this this is now
truly I'm not looking through loves eyes
he looks [ __ ] good I totally support
this the title of the movie is adorable
though it's Teen Titans go to the movies
yeah cuz it's all about like the Teen
Titans tracking down a big-budget
Hollywood filmmaker to make their movie
is that right yeah
better asked me to do a voice of one
person they talked to I don't got to be
the last guy but like you know it'd be
nice they already put me in a cartoon
recently one of their flicks they did
the Judas contract yeah and I was a big
fan of the Judas contract growing up
this version deviated slightly with some
characters and stuff and then I know
they really deviated when they were like
I was like Who am I playing they're like
you're gonna play herself and you're
gonna be doing a podcast with Beast Boy
and I was like that wasn't in the book I
read when I was a kid but it was
wonderful to do that sounds [ __ ] fun
and Nic Cage voicing Superman is yeah
fantastic it's it's amazing so fun this
is the thing they chosen for like they
seem to be making like three [ __ ]
Warner's animated movies a year and this
is the 1e Superman 4 but good friend
lady eventually they get around to doing
the Superman movie that I wrote or that
you know Tim Burt was going to do and
they let him do the voice then maybe
this is the beginning of a beautiful
friendship
nothing ever really dies that's true
especially [ __ ] Superman have you
seen the billboards all over for Krypton
yeah pretty [ __ ] impressive I know
I'm show gets it makes me more and more
it sucks me in for example the guy in
the trailer who's like you know hey man
in the future your [ __ ] grand son is
a hero the greatest hero of all time is
Adam [ __ ] strange like Ferdie Smee
and that guy that's DC Comics like I've
never thought we'd see Adam strange in a
movie man the champion of [ __ ] Ron
holy [ __ ] and he's they're using him as
a character like I salute that that's
cool brainiacs the [ __ ] bad guy like
I know it doesn't have Superman and [ __ ]
but I'm [ __ ] in they got enough other
elements where I'm like a heart I'm
there yeah I'm curious enough to watch
it but I still have something like
fundamental like but nobody flies right
well go flying like spaceships and stuff
but no they won't be like then
it's one of those like so all the things
you love about this character we're kind
of taken away and making like a legal
show on another planet well you know
people just walk around and [ __ ] law and
order Krypton the justice phage is a lot
harsher that's ending there's a Star
Wars live-action show coming yes yes to
be created by Johnny fabs now I support
this because I think Iron Man is one of
the greatest movies I've ever seen in my
life and still perhaps the high like
high bar for every Marvel movie to be
measured against still stands up the
movies wonderful it is in my estimation
having watched it now hundreds of times
finding no flaws it is like almost Star
Wars perfect and how it creates a
[ __ ] universe really great stuff so I
support Favreau doing anything I didn't
see the jungle book but that's just good
but I said this sounds like a good idea
because when I see Iron Man like at one
point they were talking about him to
direct the force awakens yeah and I was
like that makes a lot of sense because
that Iron Man movie is very much like
Star Wars but it looks like now he gets
to do something else
let me guess though hmm everyone happy
about it on the internet see I mean why
aren't people unhappy about that
it seems awaring that we're in a world
in which Star Wars is no longer the
thing that makes everybody happy
you think it's oversaturation I think
there's a little bit of that I think
that that you know we've talked about it
before the response to the last Jedi
you know notwithstanding by which I just
watched because it's on digital like so
I ordered it I guess a while ago went
and turned on my tunes suddenly last
Jedi was in my library I called [ __ ]
past kept looking out for future care
so I kicked back and went I went
immediately to post battle of crate when
Luke shows up and just bawled my eyes so
beautiful like when he [ __ ] talks to
lei and then when you know going in what
you know haven't seen the movie it's
it's even a little more touching because
she almost says you know she goes he
goes I got it I have to say something
she goes I know what you want to say and
then she's like I changed my hair and
and she misleads from the fact that she
knows he's not true spoilers he truly
[ __ ] there
so his beautiful scene but then he comes
out I'm telling you the moment of the
movie may belong to was his name Adam
driver who I didn't watch the much like
I didn't watch girls so I didn't know
his work he's [ __ ] awesome I think is
kylo Ren but when he co he sees [ __ ]
luke come out and he's like I want every
gun aimed at that man it's like it gives
you [ __ ] chills cuz you're like well
I guess if you were kylo Ren that's what
you would say but at the same time
you're like come on bro you know he's a
Jedi Master you know something's fishy
here but it was [ __ ] dope man is like
I want every [ __ ] and at one point like
before he goes down you know Huck's is
like [ __ ] and Adam and he goes you know
[ __ ] lower me down to the ground or
whatever and hex goes do you really
think it's wise any [ __ ] force
punches him across the room and the guy
driving the [ __ ] a dad is just like
right away sir the movies legit [ __ ]
funny man which is so weird because one
of the reasons they said they got rid of
the solo directors was because the movie
was too [ __ ] funny but last Jedi has
a good sense of humor to it that scene
is wonderful I went back and rewatched
Yoda and and Luke right away I'll go
back and watch the whole movie but I was
like I want the [ __ ] best of [ __ ] the
[ __ ] that I really loved but I watched
the deleted scenes mm-hmm and there's
one deleted scene that's there's there's
one that's been on the internet all week
of Captain phasma
fighting Finn and it's it's that's good
but this was a sequence of Luke and Ray
are like
there you know [ __ ] Jabba the Hutt's
and they're looking out at the water and
their boats coming and he's like those
are people they they come once a month
to raid and maraud at the caretakers
village the caretakers were the little
pug ish looking people that space
namespace nuns exactly so she goes we
have to do something and Luke is like
not according to the Jedi texts it's
like it's not our place like you know
worse unless you find complete balance
you have no business getting involved in
that situation she's like but people
will be hurt and you know he's just like
what are you gonna do run down there
with a lightsaber then what happens next
time they come with more people and are
you gonna be here next month it was like
a really dope scene and finally she's
just like you know [ __ ] Bob I'm a
Jedi or some such [ __ ] and she jumps off
the cliff goes sliding down it lands on
the water and runs and it was a great
effect it looked like they had her on
wires or something like that but she
[ __ ] ran like in a really like not
like Ezra Miller and justice league
where he's like this but like she was
running really [ __ ] fast it was a
convincing running effect but it didn't
look like the flash on TV or in the
movies or anything and she gets to the
village and there's a gate you see this
gate and she [ __ ] snaps on the
lightsaber and breaks the door open and
rushes in and all the nuns are with I
guess what are all the priests like the
men version of them or they are all
they're not [ __ ] but it looks like
they're about to they're having some
sort of light ceremony where there's
dancing and [ __ ] like that and they'll
freeze and look at her and she's got the
lightsaber lit and then the one of them
holds up the beads and goes like this
and since they glow and then Rey takes
her lightsaber and goes and they all go
yeah go back to the party and [ __ ] and
then she sees Luke and she's gone we
date you said they were coming here to
Murad and rage he's like they are in a
way and and Mark has a really great
delivery where he's just like he's like
why didn't you tell me he's like I tried
to but you ran so fast
he's laughing when he says he's really
[ __ ] cute scene but it also give more
insight into Luke Skywalker and where
his head is at and stuff like that but
I'm you know for time clearly it had to
go or something this good see did you
see that behind-the-scenes clip it was
on Twitter today
of when Mark was on set the first time
that Frank Oz was doing Yoda yeah yes
and you just see his heart and melty he
literally clutches he was like I didn't
think I would be this emotional but oh
my god it's [ __ ] Yoda yeah he got he
gets real kind of her glance and [ __ ]
it's beautiful little Chloe that's in
the documentary there's an
hour-and-a-half documentary that comes
with the movie the Jedi and the director
or something like that and it's about
Ryan it's about the making of the movie
but mostly about Ryan and Mark's
relationship or something so I'm gonna
watch that looks [ __ ] good yeah but
anyway yeah Star Wars yeah what happened
with last Jedi
it eventually made all the money's
though right it did what it was supposed
to do which was you know make a billion
dollars which is what they expected it
to do did it didn't make as much as
force away didn't make as much as force
awakens you know some of it is because
force awakens was the first [ __ ] Star
Wars movie in in a long time 20 years
but I think of if I read correctly they
were happy with what they did with force
awakens this is [ __ ] gorgeous whose
is that man whose piece is this where
it's beautiful give us the rundown come
up here real quick god that's [ __ ]
nice man give me your microphone you
didn't make it you just bought it I sit
down yeah [ __ ] off where'd you go is
this a gift to one of us or are we
supposed to sign it a street artist did
this on how I would Boulevard look at
that that's [ __ ] raw talent right
there did it with a couple sharpies look
like are we meant to signers you just
wanted to show it off mark as well like
I expected I wasn't like hey man let's
[ __ ] off that's a beautiful piece anyway
back to Star Wars yeah so I you know I
don't really it made less than force
awakens but everything
going to make less than force awakens'
right which was a genuine phenomenon I
think there were some people who you
know didn't like force awakens the same
way there was some people who didn't
like last Jedi like Star Wars from many
is is holy and sacrosanct and should
only it's a [ __ ] Batman night light
man happy to sign this [ __ ] alright so I
for one am for Star Wars series some
people online I saw expressed concern or
you like like another [ __ ] white man
because it's you know this seems like
the stewards of the series have largely
been white dudes middle-aged white dudes
and I guess there was some like thought
to like hey wouldn't it have been great
if you put like a woman in charge of
this so I guess there were people saying
like you're gonna you know fill your
writers room with diversity and stuff so
you know hopefully that'll be the case
but as a creator man that guy's [ __ ]
good he's legit I mean they must love
the [ __ ] out of Lion King because they
just keep giving that dude
giant IP I think about it dude Lion King
is gonna make all the [ __ ] money
like that movie by itself as a cartoon
made all the money now they're like oh
my god beyonce is one of the lions
oh my god [ __ ] Childish Gambino's a
lion see yeah that is coming for the
Disney app that what is or the Star Wars
series yeah because they are they're
very aggressively programming for that
app that Disney app man is gonna really
give Netflix a run for its money because
number one they'll have all the content
like all the Disney movies and like you
know on Netflix I've imagined most
parents or like here babysit my child
and so Disney movies are helpful for
that and they got all the Marvel movies
and now they're gonna have all the
[ __ ] Fox movies as well yeah so you
know what a great time for them to start
a digital channel they're only but
they're very they're very much about
also putting the original programming on
there so they're doing they're gonna do
a live-action marvelous show that I
don't think they've announced yet
Star Wars is happening others sort of
like children oriented contents and
they did stuff like they're making it an
unmissable thing smart so good for them
I look forward to see where Favreau
takes us I imagine it's all new
characters not we don't know very much
no idea whatsoever
meanwhile Rian Johnson is creating a new
series of movies with all new characters
right right and Game of Thrones boys are
making a series oh my god that's right
everyone's getting a [ __ ] Star Wars
show except us I'm just saying man
they're giving dudes with beards movies
you should call your agent that's true
you got a beard I don't honestly like
even if they were like hey man we want
you to do a Star Wars show I don't I
don't think I have it in me I'd be like
that seems like way too much pressure oh
I'd put it in you we'd find a way to
make that [ __ ] app they're like if
you're gonna make jokes like that we're
gonna take the show back yeah I don't
think I'm happy to be a fan of that [ __ ]
and I'm happy too from the sidelines
tell them what they're doing wrong but I
don't know that I'd ever want to be the
steward of something that big something
less particularly something that I enjoy
like it's like the Marvel movies I don't
want to make a Marvel movie because like
hey I can't be they don't want me to and
see like that's my go-to that's what I
look forward to like [ __ ] when I was
laying on the [ __ ] table in the o.r
trying not to die I was like got a live
infinity Wars
[Laughter]
maybe they moved it up for you
I'm just leaves might have been McKay
I'm just living Marvel moving to Marvel
movies so I don't want to go work on one
maybe you lose your appreciation cuz now
I'm still like starry-eyed when they
come out
speaking of star wars john williams yeah
is done scoring star wars movies after
episode nine why
well after episode nine he'll do the
whole sock he's gonna be the whole side
he's like look I don't want to work for
other people I just want to do the saga
movies and close it up that makes sense
but yeah he's also 400 years old but
yeah you said that that's the end of his
run I get that like why not and when the
official saga ends but that's me
imagining when the official saw gains
they always said it would end at 9:00
but it's not gonna end at 9:00 is it no
no no we are not going to be living in a
world of just spin-offs and there will
be an episode 10 I don't I don't imagine
episode 9 is the last time we see ray
Wright you know I don't she's got to be
the old Grizzly Adams Luke Skywalker of
the next three movies right for the
young Jedi adventures so she could just
be in like a cabin on Endor telling
stories one time I saw Luke Skywalker
milk a sea cow most [ __ ] up thing I
ever saw [ __ ] drank that [ __ ] crazy
alright that's sad but I get it yeah it
turns out that you know we knew that
there was like a gold rush on comic book
universes right yes remember that Sony
had bought the valiant universe at some
point yes they are finally making their
first valiant movie oh let me guess hold
on
is it XL Man O'War no is it
Magnus dr. Magnus robot fighter no
because that would be good is it I give
up what is it blood shot starring Vin
Diesel oh well that all like people like
him right well they like him when he
does one thing
as long as it drives a car in this movie
the variety much as as long as the rock
is next to him doing something Wow well
you know what he's already you know star
of a huge Marvel franchise he plays
Groot he does so this will allow him to
say more than one sentence in a
superhero movie maybe a man I'll go see
that I like the value universe back in
the day when I was still collecting
books when they launched it in the 90s I
like the books quite a bit it is being
directed by a fellow named Dave Wilson
oh sure you don't know Dave Wilson Dave
Wilson Dave Wilson of the Chicago
Wilson's I thought about Davey Wilson
the old SNL director the guy who was
like six or so that's a deep [ __ ] cut
yeah well I like that show all right who
should be known to you because he's a
longtime collaborator and partner in
blur studios of our boy Tim Miller oh
yeah he's a contemporary of Tim Miller
they've branded Jim Miller's as a friend
of mine man I could it's [ __ ] crazy
talented and then I met him in real life
and he was crazy nice guy as well and
crazy gossipy as well which I [ __ ]
love like I sat down I was like why
ain't you on Deadpool - and he's like
let me tell you and the script is by
your friend and mine
Eric Heiser er Oscar nominee for a rival
oh we [ __ ] love them but he [ __ ]
love that's a great script and you know
him he's your buddy know that dude and
the fact that he's writing a blood shot
movie makes me not want to see a blood
shot movie yeah I would agree if I
wasn't already interested that's enough
to make me go shit's got some some bona
fides yeah but they are valiant era
begins will it be as popular as Marvel
wait and see will it be as popular as
Rob Liefeld's extreme universe is he
launching something Netflix just
acquired Rob Liefeld extreme universe
he's a nice guy man
I met him years ago but two years ago I
interviewed him over last year at IMDb
at the yacht at San Diego he was uh he
was a nice guy and stuff I think he he
got when he came to the interview he was
giving me the sidelong glance because
years ago in the 90s I was like [ __ ] Rob
Liefeld yes all of his characters have
breasts man or something like that and
then how many pouches do you need
exactly why can't you draw a feat that
don't look like deep you know I got blew
him up and talked about like how he was
one of the image founders and like he
created [ __ ] Deadpool and x-force and
stuff gave him his propers and so it
seemed like a really nice guy
what is the extreme universe well it was
it was his baby imprint and image in the
same way that Jim had Wildstorm yeah and
Mark had tops or what are the characters
let's see I've never heard of any of
them
aside from Evangeline which I think he
cream on yeah yeah but let's see Brigade
blood strike sigh braid it rejects blood
wolf and kaboom are among the 50
characters that come with the extreme
universe any of those ring the bell
anybody know but that's but that's not
doesn't seem to matter yeah its IP
number one it's I tried and tested
number two it's got a a you know you
could put from the creator of Deadpool
that is exactly why they've got a stars
absolutely Akiva Goldsman sort of writer
producer occasional director is sort of
creatively shepherding the project and
I'm not saying this to be a dick but you
left out writer of Batman and Robin I
bunny is also the guy that's on
I think Teen Titans isn't he one of the
co-creators of Teen Titans show bless
you all right yeah so we'll see which of
these universes actually come to
fruition and which don't and if anybody
gives a [ __ ] about any universe that is
not Marvel and yeah I mean look it's
tough to get people to give a [ __ ] about
the DC Universe man they've been around
for a while I don't I don't
envy anybody that's just like I'm going
to create my universe right now
yeah the level of drama with that too is
like you know it presupposes that you're
gonna be successful the first time
around enough that somebody wants to see
it again to create a universe and you
know Universal just did that with like
welcome to the dark universe and then
they like someone turned the [ __ ]
lights off on the way we're [ __ ] done
but I'm on board
I'll give it a watch I flex yeah shit's
free all watching I'll give her three
episodes did you ever see the Golden
Compass are you familiar at all with the
hot material stuff I am I'm familiar
with the materials as books I didn't
read them but I know they exist god
bless you and I didn't watch the movie
that was Nicole Kidman Daniel Craig
mm-hmm Paul Weitz directed me or
something yeah yeah BBC is taking
another run at it as an eight part
miniseries makes sense to be directed by
Tom Hooper
who did the King's Speech oh I think you
want an Oscar for that I think
super-shiny director dude it is going to
star
Daphne King who was in Logan she was x21
oh I thought you meant Daphne moon I was
like she has a name which I can't
remember from Frasier but yes who's
Daphne Kean is a real person yes she was
the girl and located she was oh the one
that [ __ ] cut everybody up and got
the [ __ ] cross on it she was very
talented yeah she's great
and lin-manuel miranda is going to also
co-star on this thing right which means
it gets me yeah Wow
well I didn't read the books I didn't
watch the last one I probably won't see
this one but good on a man
it's um chugging along Golden Compass
it's on the BBC so you get it for free
oh really
yeah ah [ __ ] I probably still won't dive
in maybe because I don't think she kills
anybody with like foot spikes yeah there
ain't gonna be any of that [ __ ] that
wasn't riveting I rewatched that
recently in black and white and I was
like [ __ ] this movies goddamn dynamite
and it was all so deserving didn't it
get screenplay nominated Best Adapted
Screenplay I think it absolutely
deserved it so complex well-written
script yeah that's a good movie alright
yeah one more thing yes
Fox wants to reboot Buffy are you asking
my permission I mean if you feel good
about it why are they doing it with Joss
Whedon they they want it to happen
they're waiting for Joss to come to them
with an idea and a take but given I
don't know where his ideas went on
Batgirl but maybe he's got a thing to
say about Buffy again but it is high in
their list of things they want to reboot
like we've done the 24 bit we did prison
break nobody seemed to care but the time
is right the time has always been right
honestly for another steak at Buffy puns
I heard it yeah I mean you were not a
Buffy guy no but I'm at respect its
place in pop culture but I didn't watch
the show and stuff and I've seen a few
episodes because we had to before I cast
Eliza Dushku and Jay and Silent Bob
strike back
I watched the faith arc and I you know
got it dug it and [ __ ] like that but but
honestly flash and Supergirl give me
that and they are they come from the
legacy of that show so I feel in some
ways I'm still contributing to Buffy
even though I've never seen it but I I I
would imagine he's the key man he is a
good you really want to head back into
that country without the guy I almost
don't think you can accept that you
probably could
whether or not the fans would show up
for it I don't know but man you can make
new fence look they took the Powerpuff
Girls and they recreated them and
everyone was okay with they did and I
would have rather the new x-files and
not had Chris Carter involved personally
yeah you have you been watching I
watched the first season of the rehashed
revamped x-files and kind of hated it so
I've been very gingerly making my way
through the second season which is
better but it's still there's so much
juice still in that particular box that
a fresh mind could have done something
awesome with it and instead of the guy
the guy who created it right man
everyone gets Lucas out of their ship
you know like we're [ __ ] Lucas is
like I'm gonna make new Star Wars you
know everybody was like [ __ ] yeah the
time is now holy [ __ ] and then they saw
him they're like [ __ ] Jar Jar but and
then he did two more and they were all
[ __ ] pretty great movies and so
pretty let's say pretty good wonderful
watchable movies and then at the end of
the day they scared the poor guy away
from his creation literally the dude
sets I think it was the New York Times
he was just like like I want to come
back and make a movie but people just
can't be yelling at me so he guy you
know they're like let's give it to
somebody else and they've had a lot of
success obviously without him being
there so yeah I guess they could do that
too Chris Carter as well yeah I mean I
do think that that stories and
characters only achieve immortality once
they've been reinterpreted by somebody
new that's true Batman's been handled by
a [ __ ] ton of people
Batman James Bond Sherlock Holmes Holmes
Tarzan like all of these things they
live forever because somebody new gets
to tell a different version that story
and I think that in the same way that we
absolutely were gonna get a new Captain
Kirk and Captain Kirk doesn't become
immortal
unless it's reinterpreted by somebody
else we're gonna have a new Indiana
Jones at some point so that means sooner
or later I got a [ __ ] hand over Jay
and Silent Bob if I want to see it
continue you absolutely do well I'll do
that but I'm handing it over to the porn
industry
because I want to see a series of films
called gay and Silent Bob they will do
it whether you give it to them or not
that sounded so dirty the way they said
alright man well [ __ ] is that all the
news ladies and gentlemen the news
portion of the show is over which means
that we are at our favorite portion of
the show this is Q&A this is where we
get to talk to the audience and find out
what they want to talk about if we pick
you in you ask a great question that
generates some fun answers and stuff hey
man you could win one set of two 4dx
tickets if you've not seen a movie in
4dx
holy [ __ ] it's the best comparison I
could make is by going every movie
theater you've ever been to even the
best with the seats that lay back you
have been getting a [ __ ] 4dx is like
entering an orgy where you're [ __ ] by
20 people and you're like this is
[ __ ] like it's it's incredible it
takes the movie experience and dials it
up if it's snowing in the movie it's
snowing and the snowing in the theater
if you know [ __ ] tires peal out you
smell burnt rubber it's so fun if the
chair goes you know a chair moves the
cherry are in is moving all around if
you're watching the last Jedi as the
crawl goes in the beginning your chair
goes back to match the crawl it's a
wonderful experience and stuff we got
one of these theaters where la live in
town they got one in Chicago they got
one in New York we got tickets here for
the LA live version of it are they good
anywhere for just la la no it says la
live yeah brought to us by the good
folks at 4dx and our good friend Brett
deke and give it up for deacon ladies
and gentlemen he brought tickets
[Applause]
so we turned over to JC JC has picked
the first person to ask a question and
it's over to you what's your name good
sir my name is IRA what is it ray hey
what's up sir now you got a question for
both me and mark yes correct
fire away my friend I just want to say
first I'm glad to finally see you I've
tried to see you three times boy for
some reason Jason Mewes is who I meet
and then you just kind of disappeared
that's because I've never borrow money
from fans after the show and loiterers
outside he's like five bucks give me a
package nice - this is actually like
this venue and the show is probably the
most intimate way to meet me Shia but
really trying to see you on your show
but yet heart attack I was like oh man
one of those live shows yeah I was on
the second show good show yeah exactly I
was like damn I believe everything it's
like that must be for him I thought it
was just a stomach flu based I told the
crowd thank you I think they told the
crowd that I had food poisoning because
I've thrown up and they were like I
guess that's what's happening but then
when I left they were like heart attack
yeah I woke up in the morning I was like
oh my god this actually happened I was
[ __ ] you felt that way but yes but
sorry I the the the good news though is
that we did the first show is two hours
and so when I got offstage I remember
Brian is the producer comedy dynamics
was like you don't even have to do a
second show you gave us two hours we
need one hour so yeah so you know I was
like ah but I still want to do a second
show because I had a whole show of
completely different material like two
different hours that I had planned and
so the one reason I could be like all
right we can cancel the second show was
because I knew we had the special but
then I felt shitty about everyone else
who was there for the second show so
that's why I kept trying to push through
I was like I'll get better I'll get
better I literally almost died trying to
do your [ __ ] second show
I'm glad you did it me too I've finally
got to see you now welcome this best
place to see me mask closest this is the
one where we can throw roll-up a tissue
and throw it out anything it hurts
that's how close all the seats are so
what do you want to know so I want to
know if I had all the money in the world
to find you guys this project what's
your dream project that would be able to
find you guys you want to start what's
your dream project mark barnard my dream
project hmm is it something like based
on other IP like are we also gonna go
and buy some awesome [ __ ] did we do that
yes yeah you have like pools of gold
that you see him in that [ __ ]
I think I I talked about on the podcast
something once before
but I am dying to do a secret of NIMH TV
show I feel like there's there's a world
in which that is Game of Thrones with
super intelligent [ __ ] mice and magic
and science and sword fighting and
Shakespeare and underground rosebush
palaces and all kinds of [ __ ] awesome
that that you could go five seasons
telling that particular story and it
would never get old
so yeah if you have all the money in the
world let us let us go to the widow
Bluth and be like give us the [ __ ]
rights is he dead who Don Bluths wife
does she have is he still alive did I
just kill him did I just do this
somewhere Don Bluth is drawing on I'm
alive you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you
Anastasia - he's like you know what the
secret to my long [ __ ] life is him
[Laughter]
okay me if it was one well here do you
want your money back no this is so that
you could do your own passion but so it
don't matter it doesn't have to be
marketable yeah
here take your pick moose jaw's hit
somebody Jay and Silent Bob reboot I
think we're almost closed on our finance
in there but if it wasn't one of mine
hmm
I mean I used to say like back in the
day oh my god [ __ ] Watchmen on HBO
but they're doing it we live in an era
of wonders and miracles so that's
already [ __ ] happening if I were to
take somebody else's IP I've been
talking about this I talked about on the
last [ __ ] show I think but like this
week I've all right I'm gonna say it
again
I love the Disney movie Bedknobs and
Broomsticks
and I wholeheartedly believe that you
could [ __ ] remake that movie today
and it would make a ton of [ __ ] money
because it's got witches who fight Nazis
with an army of the [ __ ] undead like
and it's set in Britain so it's got that
fun accent and [ __ ] I said that last
week on the show so this week I watched
it again I haven't seen it in a couple
years and I was like maybe you and she
shouldn't shoot your [ __ ] mouth off
about a movie you haven't seen in a long
time take a watch
[ __ ] holds up like oh my god so Scott
Mosier my friend and produced all my
best work and the he's been my podcast
partner on SModcast for 10 years as well
Scott recently will I didn't recently
but it outed recently a long time ago
Scott got a job making this turkeys
movie [ __ ] free birds thank you
oversee an animated flick he always
wanted to be an animation she's great
artist so he did that flick and it was a
real learning curve experience for him
and that flick led to a job at
illumination was the home of minions and
stuff like that so he was working on
some stuff there overseeing it and he
also directed like one of the cartoon
shorts and he wound up aggregating to
co-director on the Grinch
the movie that though released like in
November like every illumination movie
makes all the money
there's no [ __ ] way even if he puts
the Grinch's dick in this movie there's
no way it doesn't hit a billion dollars
man it's the [ __ ] literary yeah yeah
it looks good and kind of slays hanging
on at the end of the movie the max is
swinging from the end feel like for kids
but also for adults so so Mosier I
texted him I was watching Bedknobs and
Broomsticks and I was sending him clips
from the movie that I was just shooting
off my laptop because there's like
things that like we've been joking about
for like 25 years he also liked the
movie god bless you so we like to like
yell it at each other from time to time
like bed take us to the Isle of naboombu
you know two bad British accents like
one of our favorite expressions that we
still use to this day came from that
movie which is like the one brother
Charlie is just talking about how they
he does they don't have a lot of things
Eggland's times asking like do they have
stuff and he goes we don't have a lot of
frillies travel law that's us
so I sent him the clip of travel light
that's us and he was like oh [ __ ] you're
watching it I said this [ __ ] [ __ ]
holds up dude I said when you're [ __ ]
Grinch movie makes a billion dollars can
we walk into Disney and tell them we
want to remake this like they won't
listen to me but they might listen to
you after that [ __ ] you're coming off a
head animated movie and [ __ ] so that's
might that's my dream i but I guess it
with the money that wouldn't help I get
I don't know if I went to Disney I was
like I want to remake Bedknobs and
Broomsticks and I have the money to do
it you know do I have your permission
like [ __ ] no like Bedknobs and
Broomsticks gay and salad Bob to bed
knobs and brew dicks
hopefully I that happens one day and I
honestly like like Seth Rogen when I
interviewed him and I D be on the boat
at Sundance we were talking about is
like you [ __ ] became so prolific did
you just make a lot of [ __ ] not even
just your movies but like preacher and
bobble claw and then future man and I
said what was your what drives you man
like what is the thing that like makes
you do it and he goes with usually it's
this simple he's like with preacher I
realized if we didn't do it somebody
else was gonna [ __ ] it up so I just
wanted to do it before somebody else
[ __ ] it up and and you know at the
time I was like that's an interesting
motivation and now I understand it after
having watched Bedknobs and Broomsticks
at 3 in the morning the other day blazed
out of my [ __ ] mind
I was like I'm the only one who could do
this that's great question you get the
tickets give it up for him ladies
gentlemen want some tickets well my good
friend alright JC where are we headed to
next throw them into that speaker's
corner and let's hear from them hey
what's your name slide over a little bit
more for JC pushes you he did it name
I'm Albert everyone give it up for
Albert man all right Albert our only
rules are that the questions got to be
answerable by both of us and create a
good answer and stuff perfect it's
actually funnies
my friend just flew into town to see me
for my birthday and he just has a calm
down to do any things that okay we're
gonna go watch Kevin Smith tonight
that's I hope you enjoy it I don't know
if you can you were like unhappy
birthday to me and before anything I
just want to say I when I heard about
your heart attack it floored me I got
like 10 texts from my different friends
you know that you know I'm a fan of
yours and it made me sad because I
always wanted to tell you in person that
the reason I moved out to LA in general
was because of you in college you
inspired me
and I just needed to tell you that in
person before
that means the world I did that to
somebody once who was it how Hartley I
was a big fan of the movie trust one of
the movies that made me want to be a
filmmaker so I was talking my friend
Vincent the other morning he reminded me
of this story we went to see a screening
of the movie trust at the the Joe Papp
theater in New York they were doing a
retrospective and I've read in the
Village Voice that how Hartley was gonna
introduce it says like oh my god we
could [ __ ] meet the man I'm gonna
bring my laserdisc and have him sign it
and [ __ ] so we went up to the city and
once in screening and you know it's a
small theater and stuff was about fifty
of us and how comes in and and you know
he's not he's not like me where I'm like
I'm gonna put on a [ __ ] show like you
know he was like I'm really happy
everyone's here this is a movie I made a
few years ago
please enjoy trust you know and then off
he went so I have my laserdisc with me
so I was like I said to Vinnie I was
like I want to get it signed man but he
cuz there was no Q&A he was just doing
an intro so he said go out chase him
down so I [ __ ] left the theater and
ran out and grabbing them in the hallway
so mr. Hartley man how are you and he
was like hey how are you I said I have a
trust laser disc will you sign it for me
it was like oh my god absolutely and so
he's going he goes to sign it and I go
you made me want to be a filmmaker I'm
gonna go to film school in Vancouver
because I saw trust and he goes thank
you and he's writing insanely slow and
how only has three letters in it you
know so finally I didn't know how else
to say and I was like hurry up man the
movie started and he looked up and he
was like okay and then finished it went
back and watched the flick but I know
how important that is to sometimes tell
the people that that made you think
maybe I can do this [ __ ] so that means
the world thank you thank you and so
yeah my question was going to be whether
like is ready flare one did you start
great attention in South by Southwest
and I want to know what you guys thought
of it if you were guys are excited but I
just read some news online
he's my friend she showed it to me and I
was like I couldn't believe it I started
looking but Stephen Hawking just passed
away are you [ __ ] [ __ ] Twitter
it's blowing up right now yeah Wow and
it I was like floral I was floored I
stopped listening for like five minutes
I've all just two shows I was blown away
and I maybe take a few minutes when we
talk about him and see what a good
thought man that you know what that wins
you tickets give it up for this guy
that's that's all hard Stephen Hawking
didn't mean that much to me and I don't
mean that in a shitty way like [ __ ]
him I'm sad that he's passed but I I'm
I'm not smart enough to understand the
[ __ ] that he was interested in you
I read brief history of time I read his
book did you really I did really though
I swear from cover to cover
well I left out the appendices because
there's a lot of smart [ __ ] back there
fair enough just can't get into me like
when the book got smart I put it down
but like I figured that I loved science
fiction enough to actually want to read
a little science so that when it comes
time for me to make science fiction I
would at least only have to make up half
of it you know we're not the lie as much
but I swear this makes sense totally but
I think the idea of a getting a culture
to appreciate and embrace science in a
real way like Carl Sagan did it first
and and then [ __ ] Stephen Hawking and
then Neil deGrasse Tyson the idea that
learning about the world around us and
examining it in a real way and doing the
deep [ __ ] thoughts about how reality
works and how the fabric of time works
and all of that stuff is a improbable
feet and and a thing for which we should
all be grateful for because without
people doing that big thinking and
making it relatable to everybody you
know that's always the problem of like I
don't understand science but I'd like it
when it works for me but being able to
explain the way the universe works to
people who don't have advanced degrees
to people who can't speak in numbers to
people who just want to know why the sky
is blue and white time does what
does is is a good is a platonic good I
think and so for anybody who helps you
know a [ __ ] fourteen-year-old kid
kind of wrap his brain around the way
the world works
like you know Godspeed and he [ __ ] a
lot of nurses even when he couldn't move
so I should be so lucky as to have that
kind of impulse when nothing in my body
works with my brain this is also I mean
we should point out like he did some of
the biggest thinking on this planet from
the confines of the [ __ ] wheelchair
and and with the inability to actually
verbally communicate you know the guy's
a living example of of can do for Christ
sakes like so many of us alike I can't
do it this guy did it and he really
couldn't and shouldn't have been able to
do it but [ __ ] found a way to do it
inspiring to say the least he forgot
about the nurses is that true that's
super true he's very but he was he was
our men how weird that you like I know
about Steve it's life saw that movies a
[ __ ] pervert
oh is that what happened in the movie
[ __ ] nurses no he was he did he he was
married to Felicity Jones yes they had a
somewhat open relationship get out of
here yeah and she's like I'm off to save
the galaxy right a bit but he was he
wasn't meant at in as much as we ever
had a mint at by my will alone do I set
my mind in motion by the juice instead
moving to the thoughts acquire speed the
speed acquire thought it looks a choir
staying and I will alone do I set my
mind in motion hey we should go back to
the other question we should take all
the [ __ ] money he was offering us
make the dunes series the commentary
that's really what we should do just get
together for commentary track we love
the old do but you've read the book I
read the book you're a fan you go deeper
than whales [ __ ] deepest deep did you
like glitches version I did like Lindsey
I do watch the miniseries version on
cell phone I've watched all of it I've
watched the Alan Smithee cut of the
David Lynch version alright just four
and a half hours long with all the extra
information a lot of exposition
it's just it's exposition with a little
bit of punching and weirding modules but
I loved it to death
my name is a killing
right on man that's a great question
are you bored oh no uh actually see you
know Stephen Hawking was I guess it's
weird but he cousin Eddie Redmayne
everyone just kept telling me for years
you look like Stephen Hawking so you're
like I'm really affected by his death
like seeing my own in advance oh he got
me to meet people like I wouldn't
actually meet because they're just be
like you look Stephen Hawking's Drive a
conversation even though I'd be like I
don't look at Stephen Hawking I look
like B Redmayne you like how to look
like organs I look like the fierce
creatures guy or whatever what's it
called fantastic fantastic piece Jupiter
ascending but that's just me yeah at
least spiny cosplay something relevant
to him because it was like cosmos
Stephen Hawking that might not work out
too well and cosplay like I think a lot
of people would be mystified if you
weren't in the chair like if you're
healthy Stephen Hawking's people like
who are you like I'm healthy Stephen
Hawking's like you're a piece of [ __ ]
I'm Stephen Hawking you got a wish come
true
[Laughter]
you got me tickets we got another one
what's up guy how are you I'm great how
are you about six more inches six more
days oh I lied now two inches that way
no no no right down the barrel here
there you sorry my first time no worries
abili me we're still dealing with it are
so thank you hey I'm very happy to see
here thank you I'm waiting for the one
person who gets up and it's like I wish
you died I anyway here's my question I
flew all the way from San Francisco to
see you right thank you for liking my
tweet on the way here I almost died well
you know lift is a lift as a [ __ ] it
was rough what happened did you get
robbed by a lyft drivers LA and lyft
like it's fast in the Furious on the way
here oh really
crazy ruff you know that's my kind of
lift driver somebody who drives like an
[ __ ]
he got me here on time yeah but you know
LA traffic we don't know where to go
miles
oh god don't I got on I have a question
okay Maura what contacts first been
falling the podcast and it's about
2013-2014 okay oh your message has been
hey if you got a creative endeavor do it
yes just do it on my way home that one
day probably interviewing Scott
Schneider I don't remember who 2014 ish
hmm I wrote a four-issue miniseries
Wednesday of last week first issue came
out the [ __ ] give it up for a man that's
awesome thank you
identity stunt Idol mark OSHA is a
publisher and what is the title identity
identity stunt like publicity stunt
identity stunt identity stunt this
podcast was the major influence to get
me to do it oh my so thank you I mean
I've been following your career since
like the 90s so but your message of just
go out there and [ __ ] do it you got
me to do it and you own something you
created so yeah there's something
there's something now or two something
else which I can't talk about which is
even better all right stay tuned now
because of that my question is yeah
first of all can I give you guys an
ashcan oh yeah of course thank you ash
can edition of the Marco shows based out
of the UK I have not gotten my comp
copies yet it's only been about five six
days so give me a few days I had to
print these up at my day job earlier
today just to bring them to you guys
okay I'm sorry
Lowe's office supplies man do it
hi you are you the writer I'm the writer
who is your arbitrator Coleman when he
is the current artist on kiss versus
army a darkness from yes I'm very
fortunate kill my question is given that
you are both a creator and a comic shop
owner and Mark given the era creator of
both genius and I have every single
title to your wrote for wall storm how
do I get my comic in as many hands and
on as many devices as possible as a
comic book store owner the first
answered leaps to mind is new comic book
day okay but you know at that point they
do that as a loss leader the big
companies produce like a title that
everyone likes at a very inexpensive to
free rate like for for the comic book
stores to buy and then they give them
out on new comic book day that to me is
the easiest way but the cost is on you
number one you have to get them to make
you one of the official free comic book
day books and then you have to print a
[ __ ] ton of free comic books but
shouldn't be a problem that creates
interest where maybe there was none and
awareness and stuff like that social
media of course is like that's where I
get anything done these days I don't
know if I have the same reach that's my
true without the same reach still usable
here this is a little inside baseball we
do a lot of live shows and yes granted I
you know I've got a long tail and people
like hey it's that [ __ ] guy but in
order to put asses and seats in all of
those live shows sometimes we take out
Facebook ads and they [ __ ] work like
crazy you're able to target and hit like
areas that you're going to and stuff or
where it's coming out rolling it out
perhaps pop and bike I mean this sounds
[ __ ] stupid and quaint but I love the
movie Coal Miner's Daughter and they
[ __ ] distributed her first record
just driving around and going to radio
stations and [ __ ] so if think about was
for a wall in a book I'd go to every
[ __ ] comic book store and just be
like here man stack him in Iraq I mean
10 copies this book Zambia plans to hit
every comic store that can possibly hit
in California Nevada you I mean at the
end of the day it's like you got to slip
it to them like there was a time in my
career where
somebody would pay money to help me
schlep it to people like when I was
making movies with Miramax and Disney
and stuff but you know early on God 10
12 15 years ago like I realized that
like if you really love it you'll you'll
[ __ ] and stick with it that's why I
like making movies and going on tour
with them because when you make a movie
and just put it out there like yes it's
wonderful and has its own results but
living with that thing every day like
you know how much you put into that you
know what you did to get it here and
stuff like that if you're also willing
to see it on its next stage of life
which is the most important creatives
never think about the next step like
getting it done is a monumental effort
but in this current climate you've got
to know how to sell your [ __ ] as well
you got to be the person like Stanley
always did it honestly the example has
always been in our midst Stanley was not
content to just be the guy that wrote
Marvel comics nor is he content to be
the guy that you know was the
editor-in-chief of Marvel Comics and
stuff he would go out and tub them he
would go out and talk to anybody that
wanted to talk about comics put him on
TV put him in a college and [ __ ] like
that he believed in the work so I've
always felt the same way about my [ __ ]
I'm like I'll go out there in the world
and [ __ ] I'll go to people and [ __ ]
because I love the work when I toured
red state I was at every public
screening of the movie that we ever had
in the United States so I got to watch
sleight thank you I got to watch
everybody's like reactions there was no
screening of that movie that I wasn't
that and stuff now you shouldn't ever
aim for that in the movie business you
should always want to hit as many
[ __ ] people as possible but for me I
was like I don't know this movie works
this way we toured it and stuff so I I
advocate for by any means necessary but
I do advocate strongly for like pop in I
remember we had the stash two years into
Jay and Silent Bob's secret stash
don't remember who it was but a guy came
in to the store and he goes hey and he
walks to the back rack and he comes back
up with like ten copies of a book and
he's like I wrote this and he just
started signing it and I was like oh
thank you like you know we didn't have
an internet to check like a
like let's see if he's the guy but he
signed all the copies and stuff and he's
like any time I'm in a store that was my
book I sign it and I'm like that's kind
of [ __ ] cool is that an invite when I
fly to Jersey yes absolutely you want
you want to look for Mike zapcic he's
the nice one I follow your show so yes
Walter Walters got a thing about [ __ ]
free comic book day he's like free
that's against the [ __ ] business
but that's what I would suggest you as a
dude who used to be in the press and who
covered comics for a long time so much
of the reason why I would open one book
over another book was because I had some
sense of a personal connection to the
book from the artist okay from the
writer from the whatever like tell me
that I give you my pitch well I don't
have a place to put it but what I'm
saying is that narrative
is what will ultimately change the
decision of an editor to either open the
email or open the book or not you know
and it's a theme that I've that I've
kind of learned I've been pitching a TV
show for the last couple of weeks and so
much about how that works and so much
about why that works is because they
understand I make it abundantly clear
why I'm the only person in the world who
could tell this story why I'm the guy
why it means so much to me and being
able to convey that helps other people
understand why they should open this
book and take a look because if you can
sell them on why it's personal to you
and why it's the thing you've been
burning to do and why it means
everything to you that you're sending
emails personally that you've gotten the
phone number of every retailer in the
country and I'm making me cold call and
I'm emailing every person I can figure
out their address to like I love this
and I believe in this so much that not
everybody is gonna respond but more
people will I think then say hey I put
out a book please read it I'd love to
talk to you you know and and take
advantage of the proliferation of
podcasts out there in the world be like
you know what you're on one right now
right now what is it called say it again
this is a marketing tool right now it's
on Batman no no your [ __ ] book
goddamnit did you learn anything the
book is called sorry the book is your
own
it's called identity stunts where can
they get it the folks get it on
comiXology
right now or via comics solidi and mark
OSHA publishing the publisher putting
out the book that gave us a great [ __ ]
[ __ ] to talk about you win tickets you
man thank you find me a lady
we have a lady person yeah thank you
that means the world be creative folks
like make something hey how are you that
is an awesome necklace what is the
necklace no but mark said that as an
awesome sorry Tiki oh it's a TKO yes
Creature from the Black Lagoon oh oh
it's the Tiki of the creatures Robyn
kissing its Batman Robin to make it out
oh my god that's so hot
I must apologize I came the show before
your heart attack here I left half hour
early because Tim Curry was gonna be at
a Tim Curry art show and I felt that a
nice neke tablet oh my god
you are you have my permission to leave
me if Tim Curry is anywhere near my
question to both of you because you're
both Papa bear's far away slide slide
over though there you go um you were
talking about Bedknobs and Broomsticks
yes that was mine in my dad's favorite
movie want us to get up and cry a little
bit cuz wonderful sway but so like we
would a birdie to each other
what is your guys's favorite to be with
your children what a great question I'm
sorry about your dad don't we all wish
our dads could live forever [ __ ] what
was the movie with I'll tell you the
movie I had with my dad which we didn't
like Oh rewatch and rewatch because mind
you when I was growing up there weren't
even VCRs so you didn't have like I want
to watch this on-demand and [ __ ] but the
movie that meant the most to me that he
brought me to CG would always take me to
the flicks was
the world according to GARP because he
took me to I was 13 love that movie and
that's not my mom's really that is not a
movie for 13 years and he like trusted
me was one of those like you know
sometimes you see in movies and TV a
father shares a beer with their kid and
stuff that was never gonna happen we
weren't real drinkers but he took me to
see a movie that he was like you can
handle this but don't tell your mother
you know so we had world according to
GARP me and my kid China thing of all
the [ __ ] that we watched together what
was the thing we watched the most it
wasn't I mean we watched of course every
[ __ ] Disney movie and every Pixar and
stuff but the one that we watched
repeatedly other than when she was kid
Elmo Palooza god bless you which has Jon
Stewart in it was raw rot Rodney the
reindeer it was a BBC cartoon they made
two of them and Rob Robbie the reindeer
Robbie the reindeer they did a version
in the states where Ben Stiller voiced
it and I think true Barrymore did the
girl reindeer but in England it was by
there's all British cast it looks like
the claymation kind of affair but it's
the story about like a reindeer he's is
his dad was Rudolph so he's a legacy but
he [ __ ] sucks at the job and he
doesn't take it very seriously and then
he has to train with an old [ __ ]
mystical reindeer and [ __ ] who's got
like one eye and and and learned to be
better and the movie has jokes like or
just special it's only half hour has
jokes like they're playing that song
crazy oh we're never gonna survive the
seal song and Santa Claus comes up to
the mic to stop the party and he throws
fish at a seal who was singing the song
and then he goes thank you seal you know
and then it goes on
I watched that with the kid so much that
we knew every line so I would say Robby
the reindeer's is the one for Mom you
I've my kids are 18 months apart the the
girl is older the boy is younger because
that's you know I only have two and I
talked before on the podcast about the
fact that my daughter's autistic and for
her
her favorite movie of all time the only
movie that to date she's now 15 years
old that she will watch from beginning
to end and not get up not lose attention
its Finding Nemo
so I've seen Finding Nemo 832 times so
when and she's this was when she was
like five or so five and a half we had
taken the kids that was a there was an
autistic friendly screening in Jersey it
was on a [ __ ] Matawan Avenue I think
what is the idea behind an autistic
friendly idea is that all of the people
who show up know the population that
they're going to deal with the lights
are brighter because sometimes the dark
scares the kids but the sound is lesser
so you're not startling so you're not
getting kids who have sort of you know
sensory issues aren't getting triggered
by it that's thoughtful they do that a
lot AMC does it on a fairly regular
basis you should you're like this second
Saturday after movie comes out the first
show in the morning on a Saturday is
always like autistic friendly that's
cool and so we were going to see and
like well she's like it was funny Nemo
let's just all right let's [ __ ] let's
drill down into the Pixar library like
we'll just go see all the Pixar movies
and so they were showing cars and so you
know my wife and I and the two kids my
son three and a half might are like five
sit down to watch cars and she could not
have given a [ __ ] about cars yeah but
none of us did so except for my son
because that was the first time he'd
ever been to the movies and like looking
over and just watching his face like the
beginning of that movies it's all dark
and it's you know speed lightning vroom
and just his eyes I got to tell you you
did a better job of selling
right then and there I was like I want
to watch that [ __ ] is that how it starts
it's it's super [ __ ] you know it's
it's dramatic and in a way but he never
having been in a theater for never being
surrounded by the sound and the fury and
the vision his eyes were wide the smile
just beamed on his face you just and
consequently watched [ __ ] cars way
more than I'd want to I can tell you how
it's basically talked Hollywood that
they remade the Mike the movie is that
movie it is a big city guy comes to a
small town his car breaks down and he
falls in love with a girl the small town
and the sheriff doesn't like him because
he's like oh my god the same [ __ ]
look but with cars but that that was
because for the longest time like when
my daughter was born up until like my
son was born but I had been building
this library of movies that I wanted to
pass down to my kids I had you know
criterion stuff on open all the Disney
[ __ ] like I was the the video editor at
Entertainment Weekly for a while and so
I got everything they just sent it to me
and so I had bookcases and bookcases
that we're going to be the Ark basically
like here's here's me in a wall full of
movies and if you ever want to know who
I am just look at these movies the ones
I love that I want to pass on and then
when my daughter got diagnosed it was
clear that those movies were not going
to be for her and then when I took my
son to see cars it was oh I get it now
but for him beautiful [ __ ] question
you get tickets give it up for ladies
gentlemen we got one sentence left and
we got one question asker how are you
sir what's your name
I'm Kevin my name's Ron give it a fry
everybody Ron he wants you to get as
close to your mouth as possible okay
there it is all right one question I
want to ask you you too for the last 10
years Marvel has been like the hottest
thing you know comic book movies
taking over Hollywood do you think
there's any other type of either genre
or intellectual property that if done
right could compete with Marvel success
hmm that is the billion dollar question
that if we say if we knew the answer no
I mean ultimately you know this is gonna
be sound like a cop-out and I'll try to
pin pigeonhole or pinpoint something but
ultimately anything in the right hands
you know works that Marvel is in the
right hands I can tell you about a time
when Marvel was never in the right hands
and the Punisher had a little skull on
his knife and that was it and stuff like
that so it helps to have material be in
the right hands Marvel's killing it
obviously it's in the right answer to
our war seems to be in the right hands
right now
so I guess you know as long as it's in
the right hands anything's viable let me
think what is something I've always
[ __ ] this is the dumb pitch and it
doesn't even come from my heart because
I don't like [ __ ] cars but he just
talked about cars
Hot Wheels was so [ __ ] huge and I was
a kid and people liked cars and those
movies fast and furious and [ __ ] I don't
know maybe there's a this sounds stupid
as I say it out loud but maybe there's a
world where Hot Wheels is very
successful franchise probably not but
you know if they were there competing
matchbox movies would be like the DC
movies too they're Marvel and stuff I
don't know I don't know honestly if I
knew what people liked I would have done
a long time ago
but I seem that people seem to like cars
and Hot Wheels has like [ __ ] 50 years
of little cars and [ __ ] I just watched
an episode you know that show the toys
that made us on Netflix such a good
[ __ ] show more episodes coming but I
saw a preview of
an episode the Transformers episode
which was insanely illuminating I
thought I knew the backstory and it was
even more interesting that show is doing
the Lord's work the Cantor episode of
that show if everybody should watch it
even if you don't like Star Wars and
[ __ ] it's mind-bending and from a
business angle from a human interest
story that's that's mine Hot Wheels the
dumbest pitch in the room what about you
I think I agree with you and that it's
it's all about who's telling that story
you know like if you if you look at the
Marvel characters you look at the DC
characters there are differences but
there was way more similarities than
there are differences and and to date it
has been who gets to tell that story and
and Marvel has found the person who
understands those characters better than
anybody else has who understands how
that kind of Co life storytelling works
God I don't pray anymore but God and
Jesus protect Kevin Feige at least until
he finishes his great work I want to get
to phase 26 and find out like he died
peacefully in his sleep at age 103 but
but yeah I think it's it's about the
person who's doing it like I feel like
you could have made a [ __ ] Lone
Ranger universe if you wanted to if
somebody would the mind at work could
have gotten that to happen and said
here's the resources I need he was a
story I'm going to tell do you know what
the Lone Ranger universe would include
they're separate properties separate IP
but they were both created by George
trendle so the Green Hornet was
literally a descendant of the Lone
Ranger so you could have [ __ ] tied
those movies together
totally like it's it's you could option
there could be a Mortal Kombat universe
if you wanted there to be a Mortal
Kombat universe there's ways they had
won for a minute right they had a couple
of movies and a couple of shorts online
and they were not bad right well yeah if
you are to blow it out you absolutely
could if somebody has the vision to tie
all that [ __ ] together and put on a
spider web that none of us can resist
you know what there's a genre that I
think if done with the same attention at
the mall was doing it could compete
because a lot of the elements that
Marvel
these films comes from these movies
which are kung-fu movies yeah I think if
people got and did Coakley's it took
great stories with great characters and
most kick-ass action scenes you ever
seen those movies could directly compete
with Marvel films I mean but I would
make the argument that like they they
they are here let matrix was one giant
[ __ ] kung fu movie that was
reinvigorate a weird way and John wick
is also kind of in its own way
comfortably but yeah I mean absolutely I
don't think that's a style of movie
we'll never go out of style because
because people like me will sit there
and be like I can't believe a human
being did that like that's possible like
I can barely [ __ ] walk to the
bathroom and this guy just took out six
people I believe I agree with you
absolutely yeah I mean I think that
you're right the matrix was that thing
and me people punching people in the
face will always be something that we
respond to it's true you know like it's
as long as it's not you you know you're
like all that rocked please not me but
yeah I mean and there are some genres
that will always come back in and out of
fashion you know there will always be
some impetus for a Western because
there's always some movie star who wants
to put on a [ __ ] Six Gun and shoot
people it's my least favorite genre in
the world I mean there are westerns that
I've loved like Unforgiven or Silverado
and what was the one the Coen brothers
do the remake Oh - great
True Grit so [ __ ] good but as a genre
like that never held that was not in my
wheelhouse and at the end of the day
there is close to comic book movies as
possible but I had just the closest easy
that when I was a kid the only like
country or the only Western that was
into was Lone Ranger because I'm like he
wears a [ __ ] mask like Batman and my
father was like everyone doesn't have to
be Batman
but he died in mist a world where
everybody is bad man [ __ ] like
I hated your old man - he messed at all
yeah but like I think there's there's a
way to freshen a Western to make it
interesting you know 3:10 to Yuma the
most recent one was a pretty good that
was good though what's his name yeah
guys it Logan
yeah and that was a Western consulate
wisdom yeah you know hella high water is
a Western yeah like there's ways to make
that that work there's ways to make you
know [ __ ] Sherlock Holmes work if you
want to and build out the [ __ ]
extended Victorian universe that they
kind of nodded at with League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen for real you
know like take another swing of that
which the IP is phenomenal and it's all
free I read you mentioned Sherlock
Holmes I read in an interview with
Robert Downey jr. and Entertainment
Weekly this week's Entertainment Weekly
has a zillion Avengers covers including
a new look at the bleeding edge armor
that Iron Man wears to go to [ __ ]
space and [ __ ] but Robert Downey jr. was
talking about like hey coming up but I'm
gonna do this and we're gonna get back
into Sherlock Holmes and stuff he's got
a lot of [ __ ] plans which really
communicates to me that like he's gonna
he's coming up on some free [ __ ] time
yeah so I think he's definitely an
Avenger that's going down man like I
would watch him a Flash Gordon Buck
Rogers collected like old-school [ __ ]
chapter movie yeah like give me that
give me the serial here heroes of old in
one [ __ ] movie like I would take this
shadow Plus Flash Gordon plus plus given
all of that [ __ ]
yeah but boost who walks for those who
came in late the the the idea of now he
spurred me all right if I can take
another bite at the Apple it's not IP
that certainly needs help but you know
those Disney Studios were built on
Mickey Mouse and you know he does have a
cartoon and [ __ ] but generally all those
wonderful characters are you know to the
sidelines because Pixar characters kind
of rule the roost and stuff so I think
if you [ __ ] collected all the Disney
characters in some way and did like an
Avengers with Disney characters you know
like remember the Wonder and the joy of
Roger Rabbit we were like oh [ __ ]
they're all together and [ __ ] Mickey
knows bugs like this is amazing and [ __ ]
do that with all the Disney IP alone mix
it up make a big [ __ ] salad where
they get to all cross over and play with
each other and [ __ ] I would get that I
mean that would that compete with Marvel
I don't know but it I wouldn't pay to
see it I bet you a lot of people who
[ __ ] love Disney would kind of be
into seeing something Disney like that
that's great question man you win some
[ __ ] tickets well done give it up for
him ladies gentlemen
[Applause]
we are out of tickets which means we are
out of time for the show we've done it
another episode ladies and gentlemen
have you had a good time this evening
lovely to be here at all but like I as I
said last we got love doing the show
really look forward to it and stuff like
that and part of the reason is I always
learned something I learned some [ __ ]
from the audience and I definitely
always learned something from one of the
greatest writers I've ever met give it
up for my co-host Mark Bernardo is fat
man I'm Batman for this week I'm Kevin
Smith I am luck for now tune in next
time same bat-time same bat-channel
SModcast calm or youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith goodnight everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you